[Music]
the eiffel tower rises above the french
capital
known as the iron lady it stands 324
metres tall the tallest structure in
paris
offering great views of the city on the
banks of the river sen
on the way to the top there are three
platforms
if you fancy the exercise you can take
the stairs to the second platform
if you're heading to the top be prepared
to climb the
1165 steps
of course you can always take the
elevator
that's where you will often find karim
shebi
he's been working at the eiffel tower
for 15 years he operates the elevator
and talks to the visitors in almost
every language imaginable
there's no place he'd rather work
you can get away from everyday worries
with a view like this
you see the city in a very interesting
architectural way
and somehow you're a bit of a tourist
and feel as if you're on holiday
the stop for the first platform is
nearly 60 meters up
visitors are drawn out to the sun deck
here and the exhibition that takes them
around the platform's perimeter
it tells the story of the eiffel tower
[Music]
the eiffel tower wasn't always as
popular as it is today
when engineer gustav effel had it built
for the 1889 world's fair
artists and intellectuals considered it
common and lowly
author leon breuer ironically described
it as a truly tragic street lamp
that was a broadside at efl's industrial
building methods which contrasted
sharply with the historical beauty of
the city
the initial plan was to tear the tower
down after two decades architect
bertrand lumon explains why it's still
standing today
at some point fl had the idea that the
tower could be used as a place for a
radio antenna
the french army was really interested
and began to do experiments and transmit
that made the tower strategically
important
that's why they kept it
impressive views can be had from all
over the tower especially from the
second and third platforms
[Music]
you can see many other parisian sites
from here
including the louvre and the dome of
lisa valid
the view changes all the time it's never
the same
what's really impressive is how the sky
and tower influence each other here
you're out in the elements the wind the
rain and sun you're never just in paris
but above it between the sky and the
earth
that's made the eiffel tower one of the
world's best loved landmarks with up to
30 000 visitors a day
you need to pay to get in
tickets cost as much as 17 euros
unbelievable a once in a lifetime
experience i'm from mexico and i'm
really impressed it's wonderful
knowing about the history and that it's
more modern
addition to paris's cityscape
it's kind of interesting to think about
how that fits in with a lot of the older
buildings everybody come here and can
feel happy and
realize a dream
feel good
a souvenir snapshot is duriger
[Music]
euromax viewers have sent us their
favorite eiffel tower photographs
[Music]
the tower is so famous that people come
here just to be photographed with it so
they can say i was here i was at the
eiffel tower
it's not just a monument it's a symbol
of paris
and after dark every hour on the hour
the tower is awash with flashing lights
otherwise the famous landmark simply
glows elegantly above the city of light
[Music]